oh nice hugs thank you wow it's a rental
right yeah yeah
[Music]
wait wait wait
where are we going Felix
you think you'll go home
honestly
um doesn't mean the same for me as it
was for you in Phoenix
well why don't you come home with me
I'm just open
actually
can I see why Felix likes you so much
you're so um
real
Oliver
I have a complete and utter horror of
ugliness ever since I was very young I
don't know why I mean because you're a
terrible person
how do people get lost in salt Moon
this place is not for you
I can honestly say that these last few
months have been the happiest of my life
anything else I should know about well
not just be yourself they'll love you
it's relaxed I promise
[Music]